USA Mexico Canada win the bid for the
2020 six World Cup it doesn't seem fair
it was the North Americans vs. Morocco
that doesn't seem like a fair fight but
the World Cups sort of returns to the
United States for the first time since
1994 and who better to bring in to put
this into its proper perspective than
Roger Bennett the co-host of men in
Blazers and of course he has the new
book out encyclopedia blue blazer Tanika
available online and Weber books are
sold are you drunk right now Roger drink
ROG is the best ROG damn is a great day
to be alive all the terrible things I've
said about FIFA in the past I take them
back it's an amazing organization filled
filled with wisdom Thank You Canada
Thank You Mexico there's going to be a
Giant Bomb it's to which the world is
invited it's going to be soccer themed
and it's only two thousand five hundred
and twenty nine days away who's counting
okay it doesn't seem like a fair fight
it was Mexico the United States and
Canada versus Morocco yeah I used a are
you forgetting that FIFA gave the last
two World Cups to rogue state Russia
which starts tomorrow then they're going
to put the tournament in Qatar in Qatar
2022 rockin there's not that big a
stretch I mean it's up there with
Antarctica Pluto the Republic of Appeal
the ad police Massa the Wilding town of
hardhome I would never have put anything
past FIFA it's a wild decision that
they've come to us that they've come
home they're bringing football home to
America Dan and it's going to be
game-changing for the sport of soccer
1994 the World Cup was on these shores
you remember oh yes that World Cup kind
of burnt off the hatred that many
Americans had towards soccer left MLS in
its wake 2026 the amount of money that's
going to pour into the sport in the next
eight years is going to be right rocket
fuel at every level for soccer from
youth development identification
scouting to to the UA they may've made
the u.s. men half as good as the u.s.
women which will be a remarkable feat
and it's going to transform the school
put
there with East Sports and the mga
America's favorite sport come 2026 but
doesn't this ensure that we make the did
we basically buy our way into the World
Cup because when you host as a host
country thank you you're you're in the
World Cup right there's no way we can't
screw this up in 2026 right they've not
announced weather because it's three
teams whether they all get in I would be
shocked if they didn't here's what
happened today oh it's been a
touch-and-go lot closer than many people
thought the race between Mexico Canada
and the US against Morocco would you
laugh at but you know FIFA loved Morocco
for many reasons mostly they had to
build 12 stadium and FIFA loves kick
backs it loves corruption and when they
look at the US that's ready now Ted you
know they look the US like Boy Scouts
eyes look at our Dallas Cowboys
jumbotron it's huge
FIFA looks it is and that's not really
what we're looking for we're looking for
new construction we're looking for
kickbacks
but today US Soccer president colas
kuduro
got a 50-minute presentation to the FIFA
Congress which if you've not watched it
it's a bit like that Specter seen in
James Bond when there when the ill
evildoers of the world get together and
he muttered a pitch in in the language
that FIFA understands it was the most
rational pitch that an American could
make to FIFA he just lent into the
microphone and he said I promise you 11
billion dollars in profits 11 billion
dollars and he couldn't have been clear
as a FIFA if he spoke that in Esperanto
down we're talking to Roger Bennett
Cohoes two men in Blazers in his new
book encyclopedia blazer Tanika
available online and wherever books are
sold
we had our World Cup draft yesterday and
a shower of shame a punishment is at
stake here because we had one Seaton
O'Connor he said I give me one pick and
I will tell you who will win and if he
loses then there will be a shower of
shame attached to that Seaton would you
tell Roger who you picked who will win
you're guaranteeing the World Cup
guaranteed Belgium
it's winning the World Cup interesting
not that choice eaten not a bad choice
you may be going on a bender that could
even rival Alex a veteran come July 15
prepare yourself accordingly they are a
phenomenal football team their roster is
like a pro ball team of just Premier
League stars what they lack is an idea
of how to play or even their best
starting 11 an international football is
an odd Beach Club football the
Barcelona's the Manchester City's are
actually much better than the
international teams they were about the
same World Cup play because I can
all-star team these teams are just flung
out with very little training very
little chemistry very little time to get
it right on the field Belgium and France
both have murderer's rows of talent
neither of them have a good idea of how
they're going to play on the field
unlike Germany or Brazil who have a real
tactical idea but they could surprise
they could surprise Roger thank you I
know that you're drunk with the
excitement the possibility of what can
happen in 2026 and we're gonna plan
accordingly and by the way who was your
pick for the World Cup
I believe in iceland 325,000 population
as big as Corpus Christi Texas they
believe the Viking blood flows through
their veins their manager is a part-time
dentist they were here all 12 years ago
he was the manager of his under 12 side
he will now lead the team out against
Argentina and Lionel Messi and they will
fancy their chances but none of this
matters it's all about 2026 an year-old
across the nation listening to this it
will be playing for the USA with a
midfield of Christian Politico soldier
that will be 26 and Baron Trump I
promise you your brief news will be
playing for the USA in the starting
midfield come 2026 great to be with you
Garry's it's a great day for America
very Thank You Roger
thank you that Roger Bennett did he give
us sign off a Dan Rather sign off of
courage for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel two three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]